.
Was? Das ist EMS-CHEMIE?
Einfach Martullo?
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Willkommen
bei "1945 - Zurück auf Start"!
Ein Spiel, vier Teams -
acht Spielerinnen und Spieler.
Sie kommen zwar
aus allen Ecken der Schweiz,
haben aber etwas gemeinsam:
Sie sind fame.
Im Spiel entdecken sie
ein verborgenes Kapitel Schweiz.
Eine Story aus Graubünden, die wir so
bestimmt noch nie gehört haben.
Die Zweierteams spielen
über mehrere Runden um den Sieg.
Ihre Spielfigur bewegen sie jeweils
auf ein angrenzendes Feld,
wo knifflige Fragen warten.
# Les oiseaux sont dénichés.
- (Beide) Schere, Stein, Papier.
* Jubel *
Oh mein Gott! Oh mein Gott!
Ja, ja, bei diesem Spiel
geht es rasant zu und her.
Heisse Duelle und überraschende
Fragen warten auf die Teams -
und natürlich auf dich.
Du bist herzlich eingeladen,
mitzuraten. Mach mit!
Zusammen erleben wir,
warum unsere Vorfahren
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg heikle
Entscheidungen treffen mussten.
Für jede richtige Antwort
gibt es einen Punkt.
Das Team, das zuerst fünf Punkte hat,
gewinnt.
Als Belohnung warten Ruhm und Ehre -
und eine allerletzte,
schwierige Aufgabe.
Aber jetzt geht's los.
Das glamouröseste Team beginnt.
Wenn Hollywood an der
traumhaften Côte d'Azur aufläuft,
ist entweder Ferienzeit
oder das Filmfestival in Cannes.
Die TV-Moderatorin Jennifer Bosshard
spielt zusammen
mit dem bekanntesten Rapper
der rätoromanischen Schweiz,
Ivo Orlik aka Giganto.
* Er rappt auf Rätoromanisch. *
Sie sind Team Jennifer und Ivo.
Die beiden
gelten als Geheimfavoriten.
Jenny hat nämlich
Geschichte studiert.
Wir müssen hier rüber.
- Wo ist das hier?
"Duell".
Jennifer und Ivo
starten gleich mit einem Duell
und fordern die beiden Romands
heraus.
Jedes Team muss mit richtigen
Antworten abwechslungsweise punkten,
bis eines falschliegt
oder nicht mehr weiterweiss.
Hier die Aufgabe:
Alors, Uri.
- Your turn.
Schwyz.
Unterwalden.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Oje, lieber Ivo,
Unterwalden ist kein Kanton,
sondern die Bezeichnung eines Gebiets
der Alten Eidgenossenschaft.
Die Kantone heissen richtig
Nidwalden und Obwalden.
25 korrekte Antworten
wären möglich gewesen.
Nur ein Kanton
existierte 1945 noch nicht:
nämlich Jura.
Hättest du es gewusst?
Bravo, Yann und Yacine.
Die beiden Romands gewinnen das
erste Duell des Spiels und Punkte.
Check, check, check.
- (Ivo) Oh my God!
Ich hätte so viele sagen können.
- Uri, Schwyz ...
Ich habe das von irgendeinem Song.
Nein, das hast du
von "Uri, Schwyz und Untergang".
Das ist es! Das ist es!
Weiter geht's!
Das zweite Team ist dran.
Ramin Yousofzai.
Der Moderator ist bekannt dafür,
souverän auszuteilen.
Das weiss sogar Roger Federer.
Ah.
(Kommentar) Das war denkwürdig.
Sie ist Ramins Spielpartnerin:
Silvia Princigalli.
Bekannt als schlagfertige Reporterin
des "Izzy"-Magazins.
Jeder kennt es:
seltsame Weihnachtsgeschenke.
Enttäuschte Gesichter
gegenüber Grosi und Gotti.
Wieso?
Zusammen
bilden sie Team Ramin und Silvia.
Mach doch damit!
- Thank you.
Das Team wählt:
"Multiple Choice".
- Nein!
Ein Feld zum Mitraten.
Eine Frage, drei mögliche Antworten.
Nur eine ist richtig.
Alle Multiple-Choice-Fragen
betreffen Werner Oswald
und sein Unternehmen EMS-CHEMIE.
Während des Zweiten Weltkriegs hat er
in Graubünden mithilfe des Staates
diese riesige Fabrik aufgebaut.
Fast jeder kennt das Unternehmen,
das heute Milliarden umsetzt
und heute von Christoph Blochers
Tochter Magdalena Martullo-Blocher
geführt wird.
Das Unternehmen EMS-CHEMIE
wurde im Jahr 1936
unter einem anderen Namen gegründet.
Unsere Antwort ist ...
... A.
Korrekt!
Die richtige Antwort ist A.
Wusstest du auch,
dass die Holzverzuckerungs AG
während des Zweiten Weltkriegs
synthetischen Treibstoffersatz
für die Armee herstellte?
Nach Kriegsende 1945
stand die Holzverzuckerungs AG
übrigens fast vor dem Aus,
denn die Schweiz konnte wieder
billiges Benzin importieren.
Der Treibstoffersatz
wurde zu teuer und überflüssig.
Das gibt den ersten Punkt
für Ramin und Silvia.
Glückwunsch!
Ja.
- Juhu!
(Jenny) Das war auch einfach.
Das hätte ich schneller gewusst.
Nein, also so was!
(Ramin) Was? Das ist EMS-CHEMIE?
Weiter an der Reihe
sind die welschen Comedians.
Sie sind Aushängeschilder
von Radio Couleur 3: Yann Marguet ...
Je ne parle pas de mes parents,
ni du PDC,
ni de l'appartement de "Friends",
mais bien des français.
* Hahnenschrei *
... und Yacine Nemra.
Je voulais du jus de cassis
ou d'ananas ou d'abricot.
Beide haben so einiges
auf dem Kasten:
Der eine hat Wirtschaft,
der andere Kriminalistik studiert.
Team Yann und Yacine.
Okay, it's our turn.
Tu veux aller là?
- Oui.
On va dans le lac. Ah, "Epoche".
"Epoche".
Sie wählen als ersten Schritt
das Feld "Epoche",
wo allgemeine Fragen
zur Nachkriegszeit warten.
Bist du bereit?
Je ne sais pas. 902 ...
2'000 ...
- 4'520.
Il y a 25 cantons en 1945.
Ja, wir hätten es gerne genau,
s'il vous plaît.
Trois?
Mais je dirais trois.
(Silvia) He's more woke than you.
- I think.
(Ramin)
(Jennifer)
Maybe in 1945 a bit more than three.
Leider falsch! Sogar weit daneben.
Kein Kanton kannte nach dem Krieg
das Frauenstimmrecht.
Erst 1959 wurde es zuerst
in der Waadt eingeführt,
zuletzt in Appenzell Innerrhoden.
Das Bundesgericht
zwang 1990 den Kanton,
das Frauenstimmrecht einzuführen -
gegen den Willen der Männer.
Hört sich heute irgendwie
unglaublich an, ist aber wahr.
(Yacine)
(Jennifer)
But it was on the national ...
On a national level.
(Silvia)
(Yacine)
Yeah, we came quite late with that.
Okay.
Wir machen weiter
mit viel Tessiner Temperament.
Im Team:
zwei Multimedia-Journalistinnen
von Radiotelevisione Svizzera:
Giorgia Blotti ...
- Tutto già visto e divisto.
... sowie Lara Pilcante.
Ragazze, che faccio?
Scrivo a Marco o no lui scrivo?
Die beiden
haben es faustdick hinter den Ohren.
Niente dolce far niente.
Team Ticino - Lara und Giorgia.
Wieder ein Multiple-Choice-Feld.
- (Ivo) Enjoy this point!
Für den Kanton Graubünden
war die Gründung
der Holzverzuckerungs AG ein Segen.
Im strukturschwachen Kanton
wurden quasi über Nacht
1'000 Arbeitsplätze geschaffen -
mitten im Krieg.
(Lara)
Leider falsch!
"Emser Wasser" ist richtig.
Zero points per il Ticino.
(Yacine)
(Jennifer) Und: Wasser -
überlebenswichtig. Arbeitsplätze.
Es ist ja wahrscheinlich
ein Euphemismus.
Es ist eine Beschönigung:
"Emser Wasser".
Wohl, weil es Arbeitsplätze
generierte, denke ich.
(Silvia) Eine schöne Rede.
- Nicht? Danke.
Wieder Jennifer und Ivo.
Schon zum zweiten Mal an der Reihe.
Ivo, wir sind dran.
- Ich freue mich.
(Männer) Ivo, Ivo, Ivo.
Also, nehmen wir das, oder?
"Multiple Choice".
Der deutsche IG-Farben-Manager
Johann Giesen
kam nach Kriegsende in die Schweiz
und half,
die Holzverzuckerungs AG vom kriegs-
wirtschaftlichen Treibstoffwerk
in ein modernes Chemieunternehmen
umzubauen.
Ich glaube ...
IG-Farben hat einen Teil
von Auschwitz mitfinanziert.
Ich glaube ... Das wäre naheliegend.
Ich hätte das direkt ausgeschlossen.
Ich weiss nicht, wo ich den Link
zur Deutschen Bahn machen sollte.
Und Leutnant ...
Ein Leutnant ist im Militär
an und für sich nichts Hohes.
Schon, aber es gibt viel Höheres.
Wenn er Direktor gewesen wäre ...
- Den hätten sie nicht genommen.
Das meine ich eben auch.
Trotzdem ...
(Ramin) Hilfst du ihnen?
- Nein. - Gut.
Ich weiss, was du meinst.
Ein guter Punkt!
Dass es ja verachtenswert wäre,
so eine Person einzusetzen.
Die haben sie doch alle erwischt,
oder?
Die meisten.
Da sprechen zwei Frauen
mit einem Geschichtsstudium.
Ich behaupte ...
- Deutsche Bahn.
Du hast vorher einen verhauen.
Wenn ich den verhaue ...
Nein du, der gehört dir.
Mach du ihn!
Ich vertraue dir.
- Dann sagen wir Antwort Nummer C.
Hätte ich auch gesagt.
- Nummer C? Also, Antwort C.
Die richtige Antwort
ist tatsächlich C.
Der erste Punkt
für das Team Jennifer und Ivo.
Yes.
- Ich wusste es. Einfach vertrauen.
Ich finde es natürlich schockierend,
aber wie Silvia sagte:
Im Bewusstsein von vielen Menschen
dauerte es lange,
bis man all das verurteilen konnte
und dann auch verurteilt hat.
Auch in der Schweiz gab es viele
Leute, die Nazi-Gedanken hatten,
Nazis waren.
Und es ging lange,
bis man das auf gesellschaftlicher
Ebene komplett verurteilte.
(Ramin) Die Schweiz hat ja
viele Kriegsflüchtlinge aufgenommen.
Jüdische. Das finde ich
schon noch schockierender,
wenn du merkst,
dass sie Nazi-Leute nahmen.
Das Bewusstsein
war überhaupt noch nicht da.
Der Krieg war vorbei,
alle mussten sich neu aufbauen.
(Jennifer) Wobei es schon so war,
dass man angefangen hat, eine Art
Säuberungspolitik zu betreiben.
Erst in den 60er-Jahren
kamen die Entscheide.
Dann holte man sie
und verurteilte ein paar.
In der Zeit flüchteten so viele,
änderten ihre Namen,
gingen nach Südamerika ...
Sorry!
- We were talking about ...
(Silvia)
We would be like: "What the fuck?"
(Yacine)
For a special program.
- Weiter geht's!
Wir sind hier. Gehen wir hierhin?
- Ja, komm, wir nehmen das!
Darf ich aufmachen?
- Ja.
# Ta-da-da-da.
- "Schätzfrage". - Oh nein!
Bei der Schätzfrage
kann Team Ramin und Silvia
den Gegner selber aussuchen.
Wer näher an der gesuchten Zahl
liegt, gewinnt einen Punkt.
Obviously.
Okay,
Lara und Giorgia sind die Gegner.
Los geht's!
(Ivo) Ich weiss,
dass Chur 40'000 hat.
Und Chur ist einen Kilometer
von Ems entfernt.
Okay.
- 40'000.
Aber Ems ...
- 40'000 a Coira.
Si, capito. - Aber Ems ist ein Dorf,
keine Stadt.
D.h., es sind unter 10'000.
Ist es nicht
auch mega nicht schön dort?
Nein, ich meine, Ems ...
Da ziehst du lieber nach Chur.
Und du? Was denkst du?
Wie viele Leute leben in Domat/Ems?
Woah.
Nein, komm, wir nehmen das.
- Nehmen wir einfach 11'999.
Dann sind wir eh weiter unten.
- Mega smart. Okay.
Unsere finale Antwort ist 11'110 ...
Äh, 11'110 ... Sag du es!
Was wollten wir? Sag deines!
- Es ist viel zu weit weg.
Die richtige Antwort
ist 8'060 Einwohner.
Ramin und Silvia,
das ist der zweite Punkt.
Führung.
* Jubel *
Das mit dem Dorf: unter 10'000.
- Ja, ist noch schlau.
Das hat uns gerettet.
- Gut, dass du das wusstest.
Bist du mal vorbeigefahren?
Oder einfach auf der Autobahn
vorbei, ohne zu schauen?
Ich kenne Ems schon.
Yann und Yacine,
ihr seid an der Reihe.
"Multiple Choice"!
Party.
Das Chemieunternehmen IG-Farben
war ein Zusammenschluss der
wichtigsten deutschen Chemiefirmen.
Während der Nazi-Zeit
beschäftigte IG-Farben Zwangsarbeiter
aus dem Vernichtungslager Auschwitz,
die u.a. ein grosses Industriewerk
in unmittelbarer Nachbarschaft des
Vernichtungslagers erstellen mussten.
"Méthanol", ça ne me semblerait pas.
C'est l'essence ou un truc comme ça.
- Oui, oui.
Die richtige Antwort ist B,
"Methanol".
Es wurde im Krieg dringend gebraucht
als Treibstoffersatz.
Glückwunsch, Yann und Yacine,
der zweite Punkt für euch.
Two points, two points, two points.
- # Les oiseaux sont dénichés.
Lara und Giorgia, es ist höchste
Zeit, euren ersten Punkt zu gewinnen.
Questo.
Okay, "Schätzfrage".
- "Schätzfrage".
Und wer ist das Gegnerteam?
Team Romandie.
Also, gegen Yann und Yacine.
White page, white page, white page.
No.
5'400.
Yann und Yacine,
habt ihr eine Antwort auf Lager?
Die richtige Antwort ist 2'648.
Wow, das gibt bereits den
dritten Punkt für Yann und Yacine.
Die beiden Romands haben einen Lauf
und gehen in Führung.
* Sie seufzen. *
# Les oiseaux sont dénichés.
Jennifer und Ivo,
welches Feld deckt ihr auf?
Gehen wir langsam Richtung Norden?
- Ja.
Wir gehen hierhin.
Neue Zwischenzeiten.
- "Epoche".
Also, wir sind ready.
Gemäss des Abkommens von Washington
1946.
(Ivo)
You know it? - Yes.
- (Giorgia) But how?
But yes ... Ivo.
Nein, nein, nein!
250 Mio.!
(Jennifer)
The first one counts.
- No.
250 Mio.
- 250 Mio.
Wer hat in der Schule
so gut aufgepasst wie Jenny?
Die richtige Antwort ist 250 Mio.
Wow, Hut ab, Frau Bosshard!
Der zweite Punkt
fürs Team Jennifer und Ivo.
* Jubel *
(Ramin)
Ich bin ...
- (Yacine) Are you a goddess?
I don't know how to say it. The
Nazis stole it in various places.
Hättest du das auch gewusst?
Nun müssen sich Ramin und Silvia
beweisen.
Sie stehen unter Druck.
Sie sind nämlich als Nächste dran.
"Duell".
Wen wollt ihr herausfordern?
- Ticino.
Schon wieder?
Hatten wir doch vorher schon.
Wir holen jetzt den dritten.
- Gegen ...
Okay, Yann und Yacine
werden abermals herausgefordert.
Meine Grossmutter ist da geboren.
Brainstorming ist erlaubt.
Aber zuerst
müssen Ramin und Silvia ran.
Hausi Leutenegger.
- Ja, sicher.
(Ivo) Sie können auch älter sein.
- Den kennen sie sicher. - Blocher.
* Yacine lacht laut. *
Ja, Adolf Ogi.
- Quoi? - C'est quoi?
(Ramin) Man darf also
auch Verstorbene nennen?
Oh, là, là.
- Verstorben?
Adolf Ogi lebt noch. Ramin!
C'est dingue.
- Hundertprozentig.
Je dis Joseph Deiss. Joseph Deiss.
Haarscharf daneben.
Und zwar um lediglich 18 Tage.
Joseph Deiss
kam am 18. Januar 1946 zur Welt.
Der dritte Punkt
für Ramin und Silvia.
Yann und Yacine,
ihr könnt wieder davonziehen.
No!
Autsch, das tut weh!
"Zurück auf Start".
Pech für Yann und Yacine.
Zero points.
Das nächste Team ist an der Reihe.
Es ist nur eins.
- "Duell".
Ihr kennt die Regeln:
Beim Duell muss zuerst
ein Gegner gewählt werden.
Team ...
Nein, Mann!
- Wir können nichts verlieren.
Ramin und Silvia
werden herausgefordert.
Sie können alle italienischen
Lieder. Wir sind am Arsch.
(Jennifer)
Jetzt kommen sie mit den Chansons.
(Lara)
International? Ah, international.
Justin Bieber ...
Ist das nicht Nicki Minaj?
"La Marseillaise".
- "Marseillaise".
Juhu!
Okay ...
Okay, wir kommen gleich.
- "Alle meine Entchen".
What?
Che cosa?
- Das ist aber risky.
Ich weiss keine mehr.
- "Bella Ciao".
(Ivo) # Bella ciao, ciao, ciao.
- (Ramin) Das Revival?
From 2019?
Edith Piaf, "La Vie en Rose".
(Yacine) Oh my God!
- Wow, haarscharf richtig.
Weiter geht's!
- "God Save the Queen".
Okay. Was haben wir gesagt?
"Sur le pont d'Avignon"
hast du doch gesagt.
Nein, aber ... "Champs-Elysées".
"Champs-Elysées"!
(Alle) # Aux Champs-Elysées ...
Die Antwort ist falsch.
- (Alle) Ah!
Joe Dassins Hit
eroberte erst seit 1969 die Welt.
Glückwunsch, Lara und Giorgia,
erster Punkt.
Jennifer und Ivo, ihr seid dran.
Ziehen wir weiter Richtung Norden?
Willst du hier oder hier?
Also, wir gehen hierhin.
"Multiple Choice".
Der Industriekomplex
Auschwitz-Monowitz lag in Polen,
6 km vom Vernichtungslager
Auschwitz-Birkenau entfernt.
Unter
menschenverachtenden Bedingungen
mussten hier Tausende von Häftlingen
Schwerstarbeit verrichten.
Man geht davon aus, dass
zwischen 20'000 und 30'000 Häftlinge
dort ihr Leben liessen.
Heinrich Bütefisch, ein später
verurteilter Kriegsverbrecher?
Johann Giesen, ein Chemiker,
der später in der Schweiz
seine Karriere fortsetzte?
Adolf Eichmann,
den der Mossad nach Israel entführte
und dort zum Tode verurteilte?
Das wäre also wieder
"Johann Giesen".
Den hatten wir vorher schon.
Aber kann das sein,
zweimal der gleiche Name?
Jetzt bin ich mir auch nicht sicher.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Ich bin für B.
- Wir nehmen B.
Sorry,
die richtige Antwort ist aber A.
Nein! - Das gibt's nicht!
- Heinrich Bütefisch
wurde während der Nürnberger Prozesse
als Kriegsverbrecher verurteilt.
Ihr hättet einfach
den lustigen Namen nehmen sollen.
Ramin und Silvia,
ihr seid an der Reihe.
Der ist zu schön, als dass er
nicht "Back to the Future" wäre.
Der ist süss.
(Ramin und Silvia) Ja!
Als der Bund
nach Ausbruch des Kriegs beschloss,
die synthetische Treibstoffproduktion
zu unterstützen,
stellte sich die Standortfrage.
Ems ist relativ warm.
Es ist ja ein Kessel.
(Ivo) Es hat viel Föhn.
Wenn du tiefe Temperaturen willst,
gehst du ins Engadin oder so.
Ich glaube,
es war wegen der Arbeitslosigkeit.
Ich dachte, wegen Wasser.
- (Ivo) Wenn ich mal was weiss ...
Nein. Sie haben dann
viel Holz weggeschüttet.
Nach der EMS-CHEMIE
machten sie noch eine Firma,
die Holzverarbeitung machte.
Und das Argument dafür war auch ...
- Wirklich?
Oder war es die Natur?
(Yacine) But they have to hide that?
I don't understand.
Arbeitslosigkeit. Du hattest
nichts anderes als das in Ems.
Darum zogen viele dorthin.
Vorher hatte es nichts.
Du weisst es!
- Ich weiss es nicht, ich schwöre.
Was du sagst, ist sehr plausibel.
- C.
Gut kombiniert!
Die richtige Antwort ist C.
Das macht vier Punkte
für Ramin und Silvia.
Noch einen Punkt
und wir haben einen Gewinner.
Yeah! Zack.
- Oh!
(Ramin) War es der vierte Punkt? Ja.
- (Ivo) Lass mich mal zählen! Ja.
(Yann)
Yann und Yacine,
wohin geht's mit der Spielfigur?
(Yacine)
(Ivo) Das ist gut. Das ist gut.
- (Alle) Ja!
Deux fois "Zurück auf Start".
C'est quoi ça?
Das nennt man Pech.
Zweimal hintereinander "Zurück
auf Start" für Yann und Yacine.
Ihr bewegt die Spielfigur
auf euer Startfeld
und habt keine Chance auf einen Punkt
in dieser Runde.
Lara und Giorgia, macht es besser.
(Lara)
Io ho fatto "Zurück auf Start".
Va bene.
"Schätzfrage".
Scegliere un team.
- Wen hättet ihr gerne als Gegner?
Team Rumantsch.
- Okay.
Ihr entscheidet euch
für Jennifer und Ivo.
Heinrich Bütefisch,
nach dem Krieg u.a. Berater
der Holzverzuckerungs AG, wurde
wegen Versklavung und Massenmord
vom Nürnberger Tribunal
zu einer Gefängnisstrafe verurteilt.
(Lara)
No.
Wir sagen, 20 Jahre.
Eighteen.
- Damit können sie gewinnen.
Die richtige Antwort ist sechs Jahre.
Das ist der zweite Punkt
für Lara und Giorgia. Glückwunsch!
Oh! Ja!
- (Jennifer) Sechs Jahre? So wenig?
(Lara)
(Silvia)
It's nothing.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Sei anni?
Absolutely, it's not enough.
(Yacine)
(Jennifer und Yann)
Hier herrscht Einigkeit.
Sechs Jahre Gefängnis für solche
Gräueltaten sind schlicht zu wenig.
Jennifer und Ivo, ihr seid dran.
Come on, "Zurück auf Start"!
- Du bist so gemein!
Ja!
- Nein!
Wir müssen noch richtig handeln.
Nein! "Zurück auf Start"
auch für Jennifer und Ivo.
D.h., wir haben einen Matchball
für Ramin und Silvia.
Stell dir vor, der ist auch ...
Drei kann ja nicht sein.
Also, den.
- Nein, nein, nein!
Okay, dann nehmen wir den.
Nein, den. Ist gut?
Nein!
Nein, der ist sicher "Zurück".
Der ist safe nicht "Zurück".
- Komm, wir nehmen doch den!
Ich entscheide jetzt.
- (Yacine) "Zurück".
Nein.
"Schätzfrage". Gut, wir müssen
einfach höher oder tiefer.
Ramin und Silvia,
wen möchtet ihr herausfordern?
Gegen sie nicht.
Sie weiss die genaue Antwort.
Ich habe erst zwei Punkte.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
- Mega fies!
Komm, wir nehmen Ticino!
- No sappiamo stimare.
Wenn sie einen Punkt machen,
haben sie erst drei.
Sie haben sonst gleich viele wie wir
und kommen nach uns dran.
Ramin, du Taktikfuchs!
Na, wer soll's nun sein?
- Nein, wir verlieren nicht.
Wir machen gegen "glanz & gloria"
und RTR.
Oh!
(Ivo) Pro Stunde?
- Ivo, sagst du es?
Jennifer und Ivo,
wir brauchen eine Antwort.
Wir sagen, 999 l.
Was meint ihr, Ramin und Silvia?
Die richtige Antwort ist 1'000 l.
Wow, viel genauer geht's nicht,
lieber Ivo!
Das ist der dritte Punkt
für Jennifer und Ivo.
Somit ist die Entscheidung vertagt.
(Yacine) The game is still on.
(Jennifer)
Wirsind wieder back im Game.
(Silvia) Eins vor dem Sieg.
Weiter geht's.
"Duell".
Die Romands
wählen Jennifer und Ivo als Gegner.
No way! There's ...
We've already done the ...
Kennst du Länder,
die es erst seit 75 Jahren gibt?
Jennifer und Ivo
sind zuerst an der Reihe.
Israel.
Croatia.
Croatie.
Ähm ...
Kosovo.
Montenegro.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
aber sag's mal.
Dann bin ich wieder ...
- Ich sag's: Albanien.
Leider falsch, Jennifer.
- Nein!
Seit über 100 Jahren
ist Albanien ein unabhängiger Staat.
Das Land beteiligte sich nicht an den
Jugoslawienkriegen, wie viele meinen.
Das ist der vierte Punkt
für Yann und Yacine.
Nur noch ein Punkt zum Sieg.
Als Nächstes an der Reihe:
Lara und Giorgia.
Sie brauchen Glück und Punkte.
No.
Autsch! "Zurück auf Start".
Was für ein Pech!
Keine Punkte für die beiden.
Nehmen wir das Geld dort?
Jennifer und Ivo,
habt ihr mehr Glück?
"Zurück auf Start", bitte!
- Okay.
Sicher nicht auf "Start",
der gehört jetzt uns.
Die Schweiz ist nach Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs aussenpolitisch isoliert.
Die Siegermächte betrachten das Land
als Kriegsgewinnler,
das in ihrer Sicht zu lange Waffen
an das nationalsozialistische
Deutschland geliefert
und damit den Krieg verlängert hat.
Ich würde sagen A,
"Einreiseverbot für SS-Mitglieder".
"Importverbot für Treibstoff" ...
Wo sollen wir es sonst holen?
Das glaube ich nicht.
B weg.
"Senkung der Steuern" ...
Ich weiss, sie haben sicher
Säuberungspolitik betrieben
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
D.h.,
sie haben Involvierte verurteilt.
Also, wir sagen A.
Bravo!
"Einreiseverbot für SS-Mitglieder"
ist richtig.
Das bringt dem Team
den vierten Punkt.
(Yann)
Wir kommen zu Ramin und Silvia.
Sie können gewinnen.
Mit Pech heisst es schnell mal:
"Zurück auf Start".
Okay, das macht Sinn.
Da, da und da - burned.
Burned - unten.
Ich würde den nehmen.
- Also, mach du!
(Romands) Da, da, da - burned.
- Ja!
Robert Grimm
war einer der bekanntesten Politiker
während des Zweiten Weltkriegs.
Er stellte nach Kriegsende
den Kontakt zum Auschwitz-Monowitz-
Techniker Johann Giesen her.
Hat es die alle schon gegeben?
- Ja, welche hat es schon gegeben?
Das hatten wir
in der fünften Primar. - CVP ...
... SP und FDP.
Die CVP gab es wohl
wegen der Christen, oder?
Attention!
(Yacine)
(Ramin)
(Flüsternd) Dann wäre es die FDP.
You're playing games with my mind,
bro.
Wäre blöd, wenn die SP ...
Meinst du, die SP hole einen von ...
Oh Gott, ihr wisst es alle!
- Nein, wir wissen es nicht.
Vielleicht hatten die CVPler
irgendeinen Grund?
CVPler - das denke ich am wenigsten.
Die machen auch sonst nichts.
"Schere, Stein, Papier"!
Ich sage FDP, du sagst CVP.
Nein, nein, nein! SP.
- Du sagst SP, ich sage FDP. Komm!
Was sagen wir?
Du sagst SP, ich sage FDP.
- Vielleicht CVP. - Egal!
Du SP, ich FDP.
(Beide) Schere, Stein, Papier.
Schere, Stein, Papier.
Ah, SP!
Lucky winner!
Die richtige Antwort ist B, die SP.
Und ja,
der SP-Nationalrat Robert Grimm
stellte den Kontakt zu Ex-Nazis her
und schützte sie sogar.
Dank "Schere, Stein, Papier"
holen Ramin und Silvia
den fünften Punkt und somit den Sieg.
Oh!
- Oh mein Gott! Oh mein Gott!
Jawohl!
Ah, geil!
Ramin und Silvia – das Siegerteam.
Ihm steht nun die letzte
und schwierigste Aufgabe bevor -
auf dem Feld "Finale".
- (Yacine) "Zurück auf Start". Was?
Wir gehen einen Schritt zurück:
Stellt euch vor,
ihr steckt in der Haut
von Werner Oswald nach Kriegsende.
Schnellstmöglich muss eine Alter-
native zur Treibstoffproduktion her,
sonst müsst ihr über 1'000
Arbeiterinnen und Arbeiter entlassen.
Viele Familien
in den Bergtälern Graubündens
würden ihre Lebensgrundlage
verlieren.
Die Kunstfaserherstellung verspricht
grossen Erfolg, den Schlüssel dazu
besitzen aber deutsche Chemiker
mit Nazi-Vergangenheit.
Auch die Amerikaner und die Russen
buhlen um deren Gunst,
doch die Chemiker
würden lieber in die neutrale
und sichere Schweiz ziehen.
Wie würdet ihr entscheiden?
Kooperation mit deutschen Ex-Nazis
oder Stilllegung des Betriebs
und Entlassung von über
1'000 Arbeiterinnen und Arbeitern?
Ihr habt die Wahl.
(Yann)
(Ivo) Was die EMS-CHEMIE machte,
weiss man, sonst wäre sie nicht ...
That's what I'm saying.
- But what would we do?
(Ivo)
(Yacine)
(Ramin)
(Yann)
(Ramin) I know.
(Jennifer)
(Ramin) Would you have gone
to the oberster Leiter ...
In order to maintain your business
and all these jobs
you're responsible for.
(Yacine)
(Jennifer)
Die Meinungen gehen auseinander.
Für Jennifer gibt es nur Verlierer,
ob so oder anders entschieden wird.
Yacine würde auf keinen Fall
den Kompromiss mit Ex-Nazis eingehen.
Und wie sieht's
bei unserem Siegerteam aus?
(Ramin)
Eine klipp und klare Antwort
klingt anders.
Es ging ja damals auch nicht gleich
um Leben und Tod, Ramin.
Die Frage bleibt offen,
ob Direktor Werner Oswald
andere Optionen gehabt hätte.
Klar ist lediglich,
dass die Zusammenarbeit
mit ehemaligen Nazis gesucht wurde -
mithilfe eines Sozialdemokraten.
Das Resultat:
Die Arbeitsplätze blieben erhalten
und die Holzverzuckerungs AG
schaffte den Turn
von der Kriegsindustriefabrik
zum internationalen Chemieunternehmen
EMS-CHEMIE -
dank der aktiven Hilfe
eines verurteilten Kriegsverbrechers
und Top-Chemikern
mit Nazi-Vergangenheit.
War es richtig oder verwerflich -
aus heutiger Sicht?
1'000 Menschen entlassen
oder mit Leuten zusammenarbeiten,
die für Abscheuliches
mitverantwortlich waren?
Wie hättest du entschieden?
puretype gmbh / UT-Redaktion Zug
Im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2020